why not it's also a potential new log
line for this YouTube channel no I guess
it was great Toby no no you know it's
different now I've seen the trend of
people mixing all their makeup together
or melting all their makeups together
Sofia the girl no stop a Fiat stop Sofia
Sofia enact the toffee the vinegar the
vinegar a happy ending
yeah yeah I'm sorry it's via I watched
her recent video where she melted all of
the lipsticks that are available at
Sephora together to make one like
monster Sephora lip color and then I
didn't watch any other videos of people
combining their makeups together but I
know this is a popular thing and I
thought I have a bunch of lipsticks that
I don't use an another lipstick lady my
Twitter bio but I have a bunch of
lipsticks that I've either like been
given or gifted or or have purchased in
the thought that I'll use the lipsticks
because a girl that uses lipsticks has
our interests together and you know
maybe there's a reason they don't use
lipsticks cuz I am forever bound to do
not have much together
I just wants two queen beds in the hotel
room not one King and I gotta be okay
with that so because it goes had all
these lipsticks getting in this drawer I
thought let's have fun with them today
and melt them all together you can see
what shade comes out of it let's set up
a shot of all of my lipstick so you can
see all of them oh ho okay let me do
that oh look at all these beautiful and
ninety percent completely unused
lipstick
[Music]
whoa so I only 18 lipsticks not that
many I'm not gonna use any of the losses
or lip stains that I have just gonna try
these 18 lipsticks I want to keep them
because I have possession such hoarding
issues maybe so I think I'm just gonna
cut a little bit from each one into the
pot and we melt it together and then I
have not thought through and mold parks
don't have natural moles so we'll cross
that bridge when we get there you can't
cross a bridge until you get there and
if you can you're living in 3018 and I
don't want to mess with this okay here
we go
I should have brought a paper town here
doesn't matter I should have done a lot
of things differently like wow it feels
weird cutting a lipstick I want kind of
hurts I actually had to open this one
and for this video because I hadn't even
taken to wrapping off a [ __ ] she loves
a lipstick and I'll fully understand the
point of these videos but I guess
science what color do you think this is
gonna end up with is a pretty decent mix
of neutrals inks and reds miscellaneous
is like this looked up shoot
what are you are you mo mo is one of
those colors that you're like just stop
your gray or your pink this is a very
pretty color
why don't know where this what mom was
an Avon lady she's sold makeup as like a
part-time job so maybe that's where this
is coming from I don't know okay Oliver
lipsticks are in our pot let's go melted
here we go I do not let you guys know
that I really clean them on my oven for
this because I care about how you judge
me look how clean don't look too close
my assumption is that I just put this on
my oven I'm gonna say very low heat so I
don't burn it and then on these
Valentine's Day heart bowls I honestly
don't think I'm gonna melt enough that
won't film more than one of these so
let's just do that I don't know if I'm
supposed to feel like coconut oil or
anything in this just gonna put it on
really low Wow science beauty is science
and science is beautiful well the
warming is real good laughs whoa
okay I need a spoon whoa that is so
pretty
keep going guys good job
hi it smells like chocolate I don't know
why and right now I hate to say this but
it's creating like a movi color oh it's
all done I think it's all officially
melted now we're gonna put it into our I
think oh I see if I can get you out of
it I feel like I can use this pan again
because you basically eat your lipstick
all the time let's put this in the
freezer to set baking now we mean that
was surprisingly much easier than I
thought it was going to be so um I don't
know how long it's supposed to be in the
freezer I'm gonna let it sit like ten
minutes and then we'll see what the
color looks like and then I'll put it on
my mouth and then we'll I guess talk
about it this one's so much quicker and
easier than I thought it would that I am
honestly at a loss for words how are you
it's cool Yonsei right
okay too much cheese over the weekend
mr. Mike was that not well I'm gonna go
get the lipstick I'm gonna let sit for
like two or three more minutes cuz the
bottom of it felt warm the arse part of
it so warm to the touch it had a hot but
scientific make up term you wouldn't get
it its ass was on fire like mine over
the weekend cuz of cheese my lipsticks
done oh my god here it is I mean it's
you can't really it's in these two right
here this is the part I haven't fully
thought through I had this piece of
parchment paper so I was gonna just kind
of dump them out on there whoa that's
the sound a good lipstick makes okay one
is much thicker than the other that's
what he said
okay oh cute little hearts it's so cute
now what do we do what do we put it on
our mouth she said that she said that
[Music]
oh okay the colors really like a you
know red purple pink neutral with a
little Scotia black in it kind of color
I actually really like this it's like a
plum got kind of a sheen to it it's not
matte I mean science no no like a red
lip is very dramatic and this feels like
um like a muted drum it's how I like all
my drama muted don't want to hear it
this is a fun cute thing to do if you
are out of every other thing to do
hey guys that's my video for today I've
melted all of my lipsticks together got
this color I think it's pretty what
should I call this color leave a comment
down below let me know what you think it
should be called the board and the
beautiful so I don't know I'm just
spitballing here guys like this video
give it a thumbs up and let me know in
the comments down below any other type
of like makeup science hack video things
that you would like to see me attempt to
do because this was do I'm shocked at
how easy this was and how successful it
was so here to subscribe to this YouTube
channel because I'm trying to make two
videos a week but you never know is that
bow notifications so you do know other
than that I don't know buy your tickets
for not to deploy by the way not too
deep my podcasts which new episode would
tell us double ditch this week if you
haven't listened to it yet links down
below we're doing a live show Thursday
night in LA and I see typewriter this
Thursday 8:00 p.m.
our guest is deemed from the
Bachelorette beanie babies as you may
know him online so stupid excited cuz I
feel like I've only been talking about
the bachelor and bachelorette with every
guest that's been on not too deep
recently so buy your tickets link down
below